[Music]
imagine
this you're sitting at a new york city
office
in a secret location that only another
50 people
know about waiting for the phone
to ring you pass the time
flipping through old magazines watching
taxis roll by outside the window
when it happens you
take a deep breath
it could be anyone on the other end of
the phone
a teenager a senior in a home
a homeless person someone living in a
penthouse
you pick up the receiver and you say
hello
crisis hotline
this person on the other end of the
phone has summoned you
to this one of the most intimate
conversations of their life
even though they don't know your name
your heart
is bouncing against your ribs but you
feel resolved
and ready to be with them there tonight
this is the kind of scene that i
encountered once a week
as a suicide hotline responder
it was a journey that started with a
pastel colored flyer
at my college's library and led me to
two different suicide hotlines
27 months of answering phone calls from
people i would never meet
dozens of olives and chocolates consumed
not together to keep me up into the wee
hours of my shift and through
those hundreds of phone calls here is
the most important thing
i learned don't
give advice
today i'm going to talk about why
problem solving
isn't the best solution and i'll share
three tools that you can use instead
i know that not giving advice
is a tough sell i imagine that a lot of
people listening to this
are compensated handsomely to give
recommendations to their clients
and there's something about giving
advice that feels
delicious when we have that perfect
recommendation for someone we're talking
to
i get it i loved giving advice too
so let me tell you about how i stopped
back to that pastel colored flyer at my
college's library
it was for nightline our crisis hotline
i decided to volunteer but our training
was different and difficult at the end
of the semester when i had my
certification
exam i failed i was given
two months of remedial training and it
was
in that extra time that things suddenly
clicked for me i began speaking
differently
whether i was talking to my friends over
text
messages or participating in class
there are a lot of reasons why giving
advice
is a bad experience for the person
coming to you
you only know the tip of the iceberg of
what they're going through
your advice might be full of judgment
that that person just
doesn't want to hear but let me tell you
why
not giving advice benefits you
the listener not
giving advice will free you
i've witnessed so many people feel
paralyzed to find the exact right words
to say
when someone they love is going through
something unimaginable
when someone we care about is hurting
we're hurting too
and we want to take that pain away
and that is noble
but it's also impossible
pain is part of life
pain is part of growth and
even if we could craft the perfect word
so someone could find a path
out of that pain they won't be ready to
walk it
until it's their time
i will admit there is a caveat about
when
you can give advice
you can give advice when you've earned
the right to give it
you can earn the right to give advice
when there's information asymmetry
and you have hard facts or details that
the person coming to you doesn't
you can earn the right to give advice
when someone
directly asks you for it and
finally and most importantly you can
earn the right to give advice
when you've done everything to listen
first
so if you aren't filling up a
conversation
with recommendations and suggestions
what can you do instead
i'm gonna summarize a whole year of
learning
into three different tools you can take
with you
throughout i'll be using a common
example of why someone might approach
you for help
say a colleague who just received
unexpected
negative feedback from their boss
tool number one open-ended questions
open-ended questions are questions that
can't be answered with a simple
yes or no and they usually start with
words like how
what or why so if this colleague came to
you
instead of asking was that feedback
about the last project you did
yes no you might ask what was the
feedback about
open-ended questions lay out dozens of
paths that the person coming to you can
pick to go
down and direct that conversation
closed-ended questions still things with
a yes
or a no and they can be full of judgment
if you ask your colleague was the
feedback you got
about that last project you did they
might wonder if you think they did a
crummy job
skill number two
validations validations
are a tool that help us show empathy and
they acknowledge the legitimacy of the
feelings that someone's sharing with us
some validations recognize the
difficulty of what someone is going
through
for example it can be really
disheartening when your boss doesn't
recognize the hard work that you put in
behind the scenes
some validations acknowledge the
normalcy of feelings for a certain
situation
that might sound like this you weren't
expecting this feedback today
it makes sense that you're having a
tough time digesting it
it might sound simple but validations
are a radical thing they help us
wholly embrace the truth of what someone
else is telling us
and make us think about the parts of
their story that we relate to
even if they're other parts that we
disagree with
tool number three couching
so you've learned about your colleague
through open-ended questions
you validated your their feelings
have you earned the right to give advice
first ask yourself what would happen
if i didn't give advice right now
and if you sit in that question and your
answer is still that you think you could
help them
that's where couching comes in couching
connects the opinion you want to share
with the thoughts feelings and facts
shared by that person in that
conversation so you can make sure
that your advice is relevant
an example of couching might sound like
this
it sounds like the feedback you got
today really caught you off guard and
you didn't get a chance to express
what you were really thinking about it
might be helpful to write down what you
wish you would have said
and later decide if you want to share it
with your boss
open-ended questions validations
couching three tools to add to your
repertoire
but fair warning they only work if we're
really listening i hope
that with these three tools you'll shed
the weight
of finding the perfect words the next
time you're in a conversation
i hope that you'll find the courage to
step
in into someone else's pain instead of
constructing an
exit path out of it i hope that you'll
dip your toe and see how long you can go
without sharing advice with your boss
your brother
or your best friend can you have
a whole conversation with just
open-ended questions
and validations can you go
one three five exchanges back and
forth with someone without offering a
suggestion
who knows maybe you'll have a whole
conversation without giving advice
without ever offering a word of wisdom
but instead
a mirror to their heart where they can
see themselves reflected